El Banco Central europeo mantiene la
subida de los tipos de interés pero baja
el ritmo esta vez siguiendo la Estela
dejada por la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos ha decidido subir un 0,25% los
tipos de interés Así que se aleja de las
subidas de medio punto que se habían
producido desde el pasado diciembre por
parte del euro banco con el anuncio de
hoy el precio del dinero el eurozona se
sitúa en el
3,75% nunca había estado tan alta desde
que estalló la crisis financiera de 2008
los motivos que explican esta subida son
varios Por una parte está la cuestión de
la inflación se está frenando aún sigue
siendo muy alta en la eurozona está
alrededor del 7% y también está muy alta
aún la inflación subyacente la que
excluye los alimentos frescos y la
energía de hecho el objetivo del euro
banco Es que la inflación sea del 2% así
que este objetivo Aún está muy lejos de
alcanzar y esto explica que la
presidenta del euro banco Christine
lagart ya haya avanzado de que habrá
nuevas subidas de tipos pero que aún así
no quiere adelantarse pero sí que ha
avanzado que estas subidas se van a
producir porque aún queda mucho camino
por recorrer la otra razón de que esta
subida no haya sido tan alta Es que
tampoco se Quiere ahogar la economía y
hay que tener en cuenta que el pib de la
eurozona Este primer trimestre del año
Apenas ha sido Del 0,1% Así que las
subidas se van a mantener y la cuestión
es hasta cuándo porque aún no hay visos
de que pueda para